for the Ducks you actually did research
and prep tell us about yeah we had a
duck at the studio who came the guy
opened the box and the duck stepped out
and no one was talking we were just
watching the duck you know like doing
his things I don't know it must have
felt for him like what a human must feel
when he's abducted by aliens you know
like people are just writing down things
with him like but yeah we did a lot of
studies of course videos also and the
good thing with Mar is that they're
literally everywhere so it's very easy
to to go you know like do documentation
and gives you like permission to go on a
walk to just see oh I'm going to work
and watch ducks and that's all you're
doing so so that was very and also
learning about their habits and
everything it was very interesting